this time of year I love reading scary
books in the dark with audible.com I
don't need a flashlight under the covers
browse countless books that you can
download straight to your phone or
tablet like Carrie by Stephen King my
favorite author for a free audiobook
download to get you in the mood for
halloween courtesy of me go to
audible.com / Chris that's audible.com /
Chris enjoy your book
so guys I don't usually do smaller type
videos where I just talk about a random
thing or these random vlog videos other
people are very good at that it's not
really my thing but every once in a
while there is something I think you
guys might be interested in knowing
about and I think this is applicable on
october 25th i'm going to be premiering
my scary movie special part 1 it's a
two-part series or me and my fiance Sam
are going to talk about like some of our
favorite horror films and we're going to
do skits for each one we're going to try
to do a lot of skits not for every movie
we talked about but we just want to be
really creative and you want to have fun
with it and we want to share with you
guys because we've actually been working
on it for over a month now on these two
particular videos like we're really
putting a lot of time and effort into
them and I thought it'd be really fun if
I could actually include you guys in it
like if you guys want it to be part of
it it'd be really cool so what I'm going
to be doing is one of the film's we're
going to talk about is the ring and we
were going to make our own version of
the cursed tape where we get all
different types of creepy imagery and
put it in there and it's going to be
like our own version of the tape what I
would like you guys to do if you want if
you would like to actually be included
in that cursed tape if you wanted to
film one thing that you just thought was
really creepy or get a scary image of
some kind that you made personally
yourself not someone else's material and
you wanted to upload that to youtube and
send it to the email that I provided in
the description below because we're not
allowed to do video responses on YouTube
anymore they've removed that option I
don't know why but it's no longer an
option and when we do our version of the
ring in the scary movie special that
will premiere on october 25th as i said
i will pick some of the best things that
I get and include them in the cursed
tape I'm sure I'll get some interesting
things you guys can send me whatever you
want because i do like creepy disturbing
stuff even if it's really really really
screwed up i'll take a look at it just
don't kill anything or harm anything
please and i will try to get everyone's
in there as best as I
included in the curse tape if I don't
choose yours I apologize it has nothing
to do with how I feel about you as a
viewer or as a person I just try to
choose the best ones I can to make the
coolest one minute of cursed footage
that you guys can have if you want to
upload that to YouTube you can even put
it unlisted if you don't want other
people to see it you can send me the
link at the email that I provide it in
the description below and I will rip
that off a YouTube with your permission
of course and use it in our cursed video
part 1 of our scary movie special is
going to be up on october twenty fifth
and part two will be up a few days after
that we're going to do a lot of stuff
for this and we're going to just have a
lot of fun because this time of the year
is one of my favorite times of the year
i love scary movies i love horror movies
and hope you guys have a lot of fun with
it too and i wanted to include you guys
as well so thanks very much for any
footage that I do receive as always guys
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes